The Clinical Document Architecture or CDA define HL7 V3
RIM-based documents assembled from
administrative and clinical data for particular purposes.
You saw one of these when you did the HealthVault CCD activity.
You should also recall that a consolidation effort produced
the newer CCDA or Consolidated Clinical Document Architecture standard.
Here's the first part of the CDA you used in the HealthVault activity.
I have highlighted instances where it refers to the RIM.
I leave it to you to consider the tradeoffs between value,
complexity and ease of implementation that this reliance on RIM brings with it.